- La popularité de Communauto
croît depuis 1994.
Ce service d'autopartage avec
ou sans réservation convenait
aux besoins de Patrick Dion
lorsque se déplacer à pied, à
vélo ou en transports en commun
était impossible.
PATRICK DION, abonné de
Communauto
- J'aimais beaucoup la formule
de pouvoir prendre une voiture
n'importe où, de l'utiliser
puis de la laisser ailleurs
dans un autre quartier.
- Mais depuis la pandémie,
il partage le sentiment
d'insatisfaction de plusieurs
membres.
- Il n'y a vraiment rien.
(rire).
Il n'y a vraiment rien.
Il n'y a rien du tout.
- L'entreprise a connu une
hausse de 30 % du nombre de ses
abonnés et du taux d'utilisation
de ses services.
- À chaque fois que
tu te "loggais" sur
l'application, tu constatais que
tu étais dans un espèce de trou
noir, où il n'y is de
voiture. Fait que tu abandonnes,
puis tu dis : bon laisse faire,
je vais trouver une autre façon
d'y aller.
- On travaille à augmenter
le parc de véhicules.
- Pour pallier ce problème vécu
dans les villes canadiennes
qu'elle dessert, Communauto a
commandé 1300 nouveaux véhicules
dont 800 pour Montréal.réal.réa.
Les 500 autres seront répartis
entre Québec, Toronto, Halifax,
Edmonton et Calgary.
MARCO VIVIANI,v-p. développement
stratégique, Communauto
- La pandémie, la guerre,
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
des constructeurs automobiles
sont perturbées, et donc
cules rentrent beaucoup
plus lentement qu'on avait
prévu.
- Il y a vraiment un nouveaumare
s'ouvrir.
- Les gouvernements devraient
intervenir, selon cette
professeure.
CATHERINE MORENCY, professeure,
génies civil, Polytechnique Mtl
- Pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas plus de soutien pour
l'implation de services de ce
type? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne
les aide pas à avoir accès à
des véhicules plus facilement?
On sait qu'il y a quand même,
pas des pénuries, mais
les listes d'attente sont
longues, et ces véhicules-là
vont quand même desservir p
qu'une personne.
- Patrick Dion s'est finalement
acheté une voiture en avril,
alors qu'il n'en avait plus
depuis 17 ans.
- Le pire, c'est que mon auto,
elle reste stationnée dans
la rue la majorité du temps;
ce qui est niaiseux et un peupld
j'en ai vraiment besoin, comme
en fin de semaine je sors à
l'extérieur de la ville, bien
je sais que j'ai ma voiture.
- Les constructeurles
risquent de ne pas livrer toutes
les voitures de Communauto à
temps pour l'été.
Un problème que vivent aussi
les compagnies de location de
voitures traditionnelles, qui
sont à court d'inventaire, et
dont les prix ont augmenté.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-C